What happens when you have two black holes,
quantum particles and a hell of a lot of gravity
all in one place!?
Traversable wormholes!!
AKA a time machine?
Many of you guys might’ve seen this demo
of how a wormhole works.
So if you have two points on a piece of paper…
Like two planets in space that you want to
travel between really quickly.
If you fold space in half, you can get the
two points (or planets) to connect.
This is the idea of how a wormhole works…
and possibly time travel.
But for that to exist, we’d need huge warping
of spacetime, which is really hard for us
to do.
But for black holes?
Easy peasy.
With Einstein’s theories came the idea that
if there are two black holes, they could be
connected through a wormhole.
Also known as the Einstein-Rosen bridge.
You bet your Benjamin Sisko that you would
not be able to travel through that wormhole
though.
The wormhole wouldn’t be traversable because
it would be too unstable to remain open.
It would require a lot of quantum negative
energy to counteract the immense gravity from
the black holes…
it’s really complicated, and we can make
another video about it if you want let us
know.
Up until now, scientists thought that nothing
came out of a black hole, but something known
as Hawking radiation has been predicted by
Stephen Hawking himself to be emitted from
black holes.
A theory brought by Steven Hawking himself.
Hawking radiation states that black holes
are not eternal that they will slowly emit
more and more of their matter till they evaporate
out of existence.
Except… if this Hawking radiation leaves
one black hole, it could end up spawning another,
which could cause those two black holes to
become entangled
I know what you’re thinking, entanglement
with black holes?!
What the Ferengi is going on here?
Becoming entangled just means that they have
a connection, that they share the same quantum
particles.
It’s like as if the two black holes are
related to each other.
And THIS is where the fun stuff comes in about
possible time travel.
Quantum mechanics says that if two black holes
are quantum entangled there may be a wormhole
that connects them together, if this is true,
then any particle that falls into one of the
black holes can in theory come out of the
other one.
So in a way, from this Hawking Radiation,
it built sort of a bridge between the two
black holes--aka a possible traversable wormhole.
There’s quite a heated debate about this
new theory because some believe that nothing
escapes a black hole and it’s filled with
a forever increasing density while others
believe black holes to be totally empty.
If a black hole is totally empty then there
is no possibility for a bridge, a connection,
or a time-traveling traversable wormhole.
But that’s just the theories right now..
And more math is needed to figure it all out.
So until the day we can actually observe and
experiment with wormholes… we’ll just
have to slingshot around the sun or travel
faster than warp 9.997.
Special thanks to Domain dot com for sponsoring
this episode of Seeker!
Domain dot com is awesome, affordable, reliable,
and has all the tools you need to build a
new website.
They can fulfill all your website needs.
They offer dot com and dot net domain names,
and intuitive website builders.
They have over three hundred domain extensions
to fit your needs, from dot club to dot space,
dot pizza!
Take that first step in creating an identity
online and visit domain dot com.
OMG you guys, maybe you’ve noticed, but
this is Athena, she’s new!
You’ll be seeing her more on the channel
in the coming months.
Say hello.
Thanks for watching, please entangle yourselves
with us by subscribing, or learn more about
entanglement here in Trace’s video, it’s
really good.
Thanks!
Carl Sagan used the idea of a wormhole as
a form of time travel in his 1985 Science
Fiction Novel Contact which caused a bit of
a debate in the science world.